- [Narrator] One afternoon in 1999,
Mr. Matsumoto had an idea.
That idea would put his small
town of Susami on the map.
(orchestral violin music)
(bouncy piano music)
This is Mr. Matsumoto.
He ran the post office in Susami.
- [Narrator] In a
classic, if you build it,
they will come story, they
built it and people came.
- [Narrator] This is Mr. Nakanishi.
He runs a dive shop here in Susami
and he manages the postbox.
- [Narrator] Since the box is underwater,
you can't just mail a typical postcard.
So it goes like this, you
come into Mr. Nakanishi's
dive shop, buy a
postcard, write your note.
- [Narrator] Gear up,
dive down, slip the note
into the red mailbox
sitting on the ocean floor,
and according to Mr.
Nakanishi, it will actually get
to its destination.
- [Narrator] Ultimately,
Mr. Matsumoto's idea worked.
The mailbox made Susami
a destination for divers.
It made the town special.
(bell chiming)